se faire servir un verre partagé un
repas entre amis à la table d'un
restaurant des loisirs qui semblait
appartenir à un lointain passé à
barcelone ricardo poujol savoure ces
moments de plaisir qui lui manquait tant
je n'arrive toujours pas à y croire car
nous venons de nous asseoir je n'ai
toujours pas réalisé mais bien sûr nous
sommes heureux
sans oublier de prendre des précautions
et c'est pour cela que nous avons choisi
une terrasse ouverte après six mois de
restriction les restaurants de la
capitale espagnole sont de nouveau
autorisés à servir à table avec quatre
personnes attablées maximum et repas en
intérieur possible à 30% de la capacité
de l'établissement et fermeture à 23h un
assouplissement des mesures saluées par
les gérants soulagés de la reprise
la vérité est donc nous sommes très
heureux et que nous espérons revenir à
ce qu ont toujours été les ramblas un
lieu plein de joie parce que nous avons
été très frustré dans le secteur de la
restauration
beaucoup de gens étaient sans espoir
déprimé et inquiet de la situation
maintenant tâchons de voir si nous
pourrons revenir à une vie normale
rapidement et si dans quelques mois nous
pourrons être vaccinés du côté de la
capitale belge bruxelles sur la place
flagey 7-1 samedi marquée par la
première soirée d'ouverture des bars en
couvre-feu un événement très attendu et
notamment par les jeunes ce soir nouveau
retour à la vie normale
moi j'aime bien la vie nocture donc
vraiment à fond même réglementation qu'à
barcelone table est limité à 4 personnes
sauf pour les membres d'une même famille
restauration possible uniquement en
extérieur avec une fermeture à 22 heures
mais malgré la nuit tombée la jeunesse a
voulu prolonger ce nouveau vent de
liberté
près d'une centaine de personnes s'est
réunie pour une fête improvisée sans
aucun port du masque pour les basques et
autant de monde dans l'ambiance mais si
le couvre-feu et bien levé
l'interdiction des rassemblements de
plus de trois personnes à l'extérieur
entre minuit et 5 heures est elle
toujours valable après les longs de
restrictions imposées dans le pays
le besoin d'un retour à la normale
semble prendre le pas sur la prévention
mais les gouvernements espagnol et belge
reste ferme la prudence est de mise pour
éviter une nouvelle vague de
contamination